today on the matt well show we're told
that there is a mental illness epidemic
among kids which can be attributed to
the pandemic but that's a lie in a very
nefarious one and i'll explain why today
also the supreme court killed the
vaccine mandate but some companies are
enforcing the mandate anyway how should
we respond to that as consumers and a
clip of biden
uh saying that george floyd's death had
a greater impact on the world than
martin luther king's death he's right
actually but not for the reason he
thinks plus a woman drives her car into
a river by accident and then takes a
selfie while the vehicle sinks below the
surface it's an image that perfectly
encapsulates modern western culture
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matte wall show
[Music]
as you all know and have seen true
masculinity in our culture is constantly
under attack and we need core pillars to
keep us grounded i mean um a lot of men
don't even have beards these days that's
how bad it is
one such pillar though of masculinity
aside from beards is steak and not just
any steak though you need 100 american
steak on your dinner table fortunately
for you good ranchers the exclusive meat
company of the daily wire they help you
get american meat delivered they've got
100 american steakhouse quality meat and
it's all for an affordable price shop
good ranchers today to support american
made and put the small farm back on top
plus use my code walsh for 30 off that's
the biggest first purchase discount code
good ranchers has ever given out which
means there has never been a better time
to buy support american farms and
ranchers and get a delicious
t-bone gourmet burger ribeye they've all
they've got it all and more
mouth-watering cuts in the process as
well visit goodranchers.com walsh
or use code walsh to check out to get 30
off any of their many boxes everything
they sell is truly top-notch and you
really have to try it to believe it so
visit goodranchers.com walsh today to
save 30 on your new favorite steak start
the year with good ranchers american
meat delivered
the mayor of new york eric adams
attended a knicks game last night
alongside 20 000 of his fellow fans as
is the case with almost all professional
sporting events in the country nobody
was wearing a mask
in the whole building
this morning though
every school-aged child in new york city
and across the state wore masks in class
and in the bus on their way to class
and uh outside at recess or during gym
young children wore masks while they
tried to learn how to read they wore
masks to speech therapy
they wore masks for hours at a time like
they do every day
millions of children around the country
are of course in this position
in some schools they're forced to eat
lunch outside sitting on the cold ground
and freezing temperatures
further health and safety you understand
they spent the previous year locked in
their homes attending school through a
computer screen and learned nothing in
the process many adults who run these
school systems want to send them back to
that and maybe it doesn't matter it's
hard to say that the current arrangement
is much of an improvement anyway
children are as we know the least
susceptible to kovid and have been from
the start
the current variant isn't a serious
threat to almost anybody except the most
elderly frail or sick that's why adults
don't worry very much about packing
themselves into a stadium 70 000 at a
time and spending hours together
maskless and they shouldn't worry
yet their kids far less vulnerable to
the disease than themselves have been
wearing masks for so long
that a lot of these kids don't even know
what their friends faces look like
anymore
now there have been many reports in
recent weeks about the mental illness
crisis
among these kids a recent report in the
hill tells us that quote officials and
experts have sounded the alarm over the
state of children's mental health the
american academy of pediatrics the chil
the american academy of child and
adolescent psychiatry and the children's
hospital association declared a national
emergency for children's mental health
in october shortly after the back to
school season
but aacap president warren yuki
said that the situation has gotten worse
since the declaration with the scope
being even larger than we imagined quote
unquote children's hospitals recorded
almost 38 more emergency department
visits for mental health cases and
nearly 54 more suicide and self-injury
cases in the third quarter of 2021
compared to 2020 according to the
children's hospital association
so that's what's happening what can we
do about it well according to the
article quote advocates and experts are
calling for more support and recognition
for both those struggling with mental
illness and behavioral health
professionals
now npr adds the caveat that quote the
rise in children's mental health
symptoms
didn't start with this school year
recent studies show that the pandemic
exacerbated an already growing crisis in
youth mental health
and there's an article on the american
psychological association website
warning us that quote after two full
years of the coven 19 pandemic we're now
faced with a situation where quote
mental illness
as that is at an all-time high
further we're told according to a survey
quote 71 of parents said the pandemic
had taken a toll on their child's mental
health and 69 percent of the pandemic
was the worst thing to happen to their
child
a national survey of three of 3 300 high
schoolers conducted in spring 2020
found close to a third of students felt
unhappy and depressed much more than
usual
i must be mental illness right
see this seems to be the consensus at
least in the media and among health care
professionals
the pandemic
has caused an epidemic of mental illness
especially among kids that's what we're
told
or at least it has made worse an
epidemic that was raging long before
but both of these conclusions are wrong
and wrong in very important ways
first of all the pandemic
has not done any of this
okay it's not the pandemic's fault
the pandemic itself has been quite mild
for kids
we can blame kovid for
our children's mental health problem but
as much as we can blame the flu
for our children's mental health
problems
it's not the virus that has created
these issues
it's our response to the virus
it's what the adults have done in
response to it
you know if a boy is locked in a closet
for three weeks because his paranoid
delusional mother
wants to keep him safe from the
invisible monsters in the house
we can't blame her her son's physical
state on the invisible monsters
whether the monsters exist or not it's
clear that the mother's actions are the
immediate cause of the child's condition
now you might say this analogy is not
fair because a child is more likely to
be killed by covid than by invisible
monsters and you're right
but the statistical likelihood that any
individual child should be killed or
seriously hurt by covid is so
vanishingly small that for most kids the
comparison hits very close to the mark
the point is that kids are suffering at
the hands of the adult authority figures
in their lives
you can blame kovid for plenty of things
but not this
second this is not mental illness
okay
children who are depressed
or anxious
or stressed out
or angry
or some combination of all these things
are responding rationally and
justifiably to the circumstances they
have been put in
it is perfectly natural for a child to
be depressed if he's ripped out of his
normal life forced to walk around in a
mask all day like some kind of
contagious leper
deprived of of of healthy forms of
recreation isolated
not even able to see his friends faces
or show his own
calling his depression mental illness is
like starving him for a month and then
accusing him of having an eating
disorder
what else is he going to do but starve
if you won't feed him
what else is he going to do but plunge
into despair if you've removed all
sources of hope and joy from his life
kids are being psychologically abused
okay they're being fed a steady diet of
fear and paranoia
they're being conditioned to treat fresh
air like it's toxic
so if you notice changes
to a child's emotional and mental state
amid all of this
it's not because they have a mental
illness or a brain disease
it's because they're humans
and this is how humans respond when
they're subjected to this kind of
torture
if anything we should be concerned about
the children who are unfazed by the
circumstances
we should be more worried about the kids
who are not depressed
i mean it's terrible to think of the
child who cries as he's physically
abused by his alcoholic father
it's even worse to think of the child
who does not cry
because he's gotten used to the
treatment
the abuse has settled into his psyche
deep down
he thinks he deserves it
so the parents who brag that their
children handle you know
isolation and masking without complaint
oh my kids are doing just fine
they're really bragging that their
children have been broken
their spirits have been so thoroughly
crushed that they can't conceive of a
better life
and therefore don't desire one
the health professionals so-called who
clamor about a mental illness scourge
among kids
they're the same ones who support and
advocate for the policies that are
causing the problem
and so the mental illness label is a
cover for them
they're hiding behind it
so that they're not held
accountable you know they throw up their
hands and say i don't know what's going
on there's a lot of mental illness going
around apparently
that's not ill
what's ill or irrational or diseased
about being extremely upset and stressed
out
when your life is destroyed
as a child
what this means is that the totally
justified and well warranted despair
stress and anxiety felt by these kids
will be treated as the problem itself
the kids will be counseled and then
drugged
and then sent right back into the same
soul-killing environment
it's like prescribing someone diet pills
and then handing them a mcdonald's
coupon on the way out the door
so you're chopping away at the branches
while watering the roots
you're causing the problem that you're
pretending to solve
and the kids are left with the mess that
you make
as always
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so our top headline today the most
important news of the week uh month year
possibly decade is that uh i'm going to
be on dr phil i was already on the show
actually we recorded the episode it
hasn't aired yet it's going to air
tomorrow um
i don't know what time whatever time
they air and um
tomorrow wednesday's once
they dropped a brief little promo for
the episode yesterday i think this gives
you a good taste
um gives you uh the flavor of what
you'll experience when the full episode
comes out so let's watch that
the dispute over gender pronouns i don't
identify exclusively with being a man or
woman i use they and them as my pronouns
you don't get your own pronouns you
think it's a delusion
in school our kids are being asked what
their pronoun is this is a war on gender
babies are babies without a known sex
when they were born we did not assign a
sex you think it's toxic to label the
child one way or the other
now you know there's always a risk um
when it's uh when you when you go on a
show like this and it's pre-recorded
because you know it's live that's one
thing it's out there everybody sees it
with pre-recorded you're kind of at the
mercy especially when you sign all the
release forms and everything and
basically it's if you read the pages and
nobody ever does they're telling you
that like we could chop this up in a
million different ways and do what we
want with it and you can't do anything
about it so there's there's a
certain risk involved it's calculated
risk i'm not too worried about it i
think that i think the editing will be
fair
um
and i also think it's worth because i've
i've
you know i put this i posted this promo
yesterday and
most people are saying they're excited
to watch the episode
uh i i have gotten some people messaging
me and and saying well you know why
would you go
uh on a network like this why would you
be a part of this in the first place
uh i think it's it's more than worth it
to go into the the lion's den that's
what we have to be willing to do
you know it's these kinds of
conversations the way that uh that
everything is sort of segregated right
now
is that when it comes to something like
gender
you know if you're watching network tv
you're gonna see one
perspective on it
without it really being challenged
and if you want to get the other
perspective which is the truth the
rational sane perspective you got to go
seek it out
by going to the daily wire or
well the daily wire and maybe a couple
other outlets can can give you that but
you got to go find it and then
everything's in its own little corner
the problem is that the left corner was
not really a corner like they have the
entire house and then as it stands right
now
on the right we we have the corners and
so we stay in our little corner and we
don't venture outside of that much of
the time
now we we that that's a problem we need
to go if you want to reach people
um
who are not going to seek you out in
your corner then you have to go and find
them
and actually challenge these ideas so
that's what i tried to do and um you
know sitting across from the bearded
man in the dress and that sort of thing
it was a lively conversation i'll put it
that way all right
so the supreme court killed the private
employer of axe mandate as we talked
about uh on friday but that that doesn't
mean
that there are no more private employer
vax mandates because now some employers
can are choosing to keep them anyway
even though they have no excuse to no
reason to
they have no reason to because they're
not being forced to do it also because
there's no as we've discussed there's no
rational scientific basis for it when we
know that vaxxed and unvaxed alike
spread the virus so there's just no
there's
there's
nothing to grab on to here in terms of a
a reason for a vax mandate
you have no foundation for it
but employers are doing it anyway
and elijah schaefer is a great podcast
over host over at the blaze has this
screenshot reportedly from an email
from carhartt
to to their employees and this is what
it says it's gone viral today it says
carhartt associates uh many of you have
asked how the recent supreme court
decision on the osha mandate for large
employers will impact our associates so
we want to provide some clarity
the ruling does not change carhartt's
mandatory vaccination program which went
into effect on january 4th as you know
we have extended vaccination deadline
for both our cv and madisonville
associates to february 15th
this date also remains in fl in effect
we put workplace safety at the very top
of our priority list and the supreme
court's recent ruling doesn't impact
that core value we in the medical
community continue to believe vaccines
are necessary to ensure a safe working
environment for every associate and even
perhaps their households
which doesn't make any sense at all of
course so carhartt they're still gonna
have their vaccine mandate
um
here's what i'll say about this
i think these companies need to be held
accountable for this
but who holds them accountable
well the consumers need to do it
so i put the onus on us primarily as
consumers
on myself
i i have been a carhartt customer in the
past
as an avid fan of bass pro shops you
know you go there and you're gonna find
plenty of carhartt
um
that's where i put the onus
so i i think that and i do that
much more than i put the onus on the
employees and this is an important point
because i think sometimes we're a little
bit too blithe and casual about just
declaring that employees should quit
under these circumstances i hear that a
lot i hear that in conservative media
for example well you should just quit
that's really easy to say it's easy for
me to say
we don't have a vaccine mandate here our
our employer is one of the ones that
went to supreme court to fight this
so i don't have to worry about it
um i'm getting a paycheck and i'm
feeding my kids and and i'm bringing you
know the bacon home to my family
so that so it's it's i'm good
so it's really easy for me to sit here
and say well you should quit your job
you out there watching this right now
just quit quit right now today
go home and explain it to your wife
later
uh you'll be fine
now if you can quit your job
then great then you know if you can and
you decide to quit your job in protest
of something like this to stand up for
your rights and i think that's fantastic
i think it's i i admire that
but i know that i'm a father i have a
family
and that's my first responsibility
and i put that responsibility over
everything and
everyone
really i mean over conservatism over
liberty
over my country
i'll choose my family over my country
i'll choose it over literally everything
and everyone except god himself
that those are my values
and what that means is that if i'm in
this position
if i was put in the same position let's
say someone a carhartt's in
i'm not going to leave my job in a huff
all at once
and make my children go hungry
might be that might be what you want me
to do for your own sake but it's not
what i'm gonna do
because i have my family and i care
about them more than i care about you
and i care about them more than i care
about your values
so what i would need to do if i was in
this position and i wanted to leave and
i would want to leave but i would need
to secure another job first
and that takes time
it's not something that i can afford to
do just leaving the job all at once
going out in a blaze of glory to prove a
point
that's not fair to my kids
okay so i can go home feeling good and i
could say to my kids well i took a stand
today and
that's great dad but how are we going to
eat tonight
that's my first responsibility is to
make sure my kids are eating
not to make a point about vaccine
mandates
not that the point isn't important but
it's not as important as my duty as a
father
so
does that mean that we should just lay
down
am i advocating that not at all
i'm putting the onus on the consumer
because as consumers
we we could crush this
we have that ability much more than the
employees do
because the other thing is as an
employee you quit
again i admired if you decide to do that
but if you do they're just gonna they're
gonna replace you they're gonna find
someone who who who will
who will cooperate with the vaccine
mandate and they'll just replace you and
that's it and continue doing what they
want to do
you can't replace consumers though
at least they're a lot harder to replace
so
as consumers
if we say to carhartt you know rather
than pointing to the employees who have
families to feed and saying you all
should quit
that just quit
how about we make the decision not to
buy carhartt
until they reverse this tyrannical
uh senseless irrational
immoral mandate
because here's the great thing we have
nothing at stake
we don't sacrifice anything
i mean literally nothing you sacrifice
carhartt okay just buy a jacket from a
different company
you're not gonna freeze to death you'll
find some company that doesn't have a
vaccine made it where you can buy a
jacket
plus you probably already have 15 of
them in your closet anyway
so we could do that but here's what we
do as consumers
you know we we sit back and say all you
should quit
and then we continue to patronize
these same companies
we could bring these companies to their
knees
by using the power we have as consumers
and it costs us nothing to do
so think about the sacrifice of leaving
your job
when you have a family to feed versus
the sacrifice of just not buying crap
from one company and buying it from
another instead
who who's making the greater sacrifice
who should we
be pointing to
and expecting them to you know
expecting more from
so that's what that's what gets me i i
um
especially a company like carhartt
they're
i would guess the majority of their
employees are going to be more of the
conservative
blue-collar sort of persuasion
okay there's not a lot of
prissy leftists in in los angeles or san
francisco or manhattan walking around
carhartt
so we could put an end to this
we could
if we choose not to then that's our
fault don't blame the employees for that
all right yesterday was um mlk day
lots of democrats of course using mlk to
promote their agenda
but this clip from biden which actually
is from like a year ago uh went viral
again as people were kind of reminiscing
about it and biden is criticized for
saying what he says here it's a brief
clip he's criticized for this a lot of
people on the right of course
criticizing him but um i i actually
agree with him let's let's play the clip
but even dr king's assassination did not
have the worldwide impact
that george floyd's
death did
okay so there you go um
martin luther king's death did not have
the the worldwide impact that george
floyd's death had
and like i said a lot of people on the
right very upset about this and uh
upset anew and criticizing him saying
this is a horrible thing to say
he's actually 100 right
now if you look at the full context and
the point he's trying to make about it
he's not right
because he's not just saying that it the
death had a greater impact he he's also
justifying he thinks that it ought to
have had a better impact a greater
impact
and when it comes to the ought to he's
obviously wrong about that
but as an observation he's 100 right
like undeniably
that george floyd's death
had a greater um immediate global impact
than
mlk's death
now mlk's life
of course had a much greater impact than
george floyd's life did
george floyd floyd's
life had no impact on society except a
negative one
had a bad impact for his community that
he victimized for the woman that he
robbed at gunpoint when he forced his
way into her house and had a bad impact
for them
but beyond that it had no impact at all
his life was inconsequential
he was a he was a a violent scumbag
criminal
and that's how i'll always describe
anyone who
forces their way into a woman's house
and points a gun at them they're all
scumbags right
so
life life is is one thing life had a
great impact but death absolutely george
floyd's death had a greater impact and
that only speaks
to how insane the reaction to george
floyd's death was in fact
i it would be hard to think of
if you were to to make a list
of all of the prominent people who've
been who've died
over the last
century
and and we're going to rank whose death
who the the deaths that had the greatest
impact george floyd is in the top three
probably
i mean you probably got jfk and then i i
think george floyd's probably number two
and you might even be able to make an
argument for putting him at number one
when you consider just the way that
success meltdown that occurred
across society
and the way that things were reshuffled
and flipped on their heads everything's
upside down and backwards because george
floyd died
let's start with the fact that um
dozens of cities across the country were
in flames for months
and we're still dealing with the effects
of that i mean a total breakdown of law
and order we'll start with that
so the impact was negative
from his death it's completely
maniacal and irrational and insane
but did it have a greater impact yeah
in fact i think what the point he makes
there that's the point that we should be
making as conservatives we we shouldn't
be disagreeing with that
we should be pointing that out
because of how crazy it only illustrates
how crazy the reaction was
all right um
let's see what else do we got here
the michigan the democratic party put
this out on facebook we have this here
okay so they put this on facebook um
and it said not sure where this parent
should control what is taught in schools
because their they are our kids is
originating but parents do have the
option to choose to send their kids to a
hand-selected private school at their
own expense if this is what they desire
the purpose of a public public education
in a public school is not to teach kids
only what parents want them to be taught
is to teach them what society
needs them to know
the client of the public school is not
the parent
but the entire community
the public
now the michigan democratic party they
put that up
because these people never learned i
mean we're going into midterm elections
and the democrat party was
eviscerated in virginia because of this
kind of thing
and these idiots never learn which is
great that they never learn
i mean i'm happy that they don't learn i
i
i hope that this is the um that this is
their motto going forward into the
midterms i would love to see that
because it guarantees that every
election where they
where this is what they do they're going
to lose
but the michigan democratic party they
actually took that down and uh and
issued
a very rare apology from anybody on the
left saying oh no no we we believe in
parental rights of course we do
but but they don't
and
you know this this right there that
is a reflection of what they actually
think
um
even if they apologize for it after the
fact because of the reaction to it
of course if it had not been for that
reaction they would have just kept it up
we know that
it's also of course not at all true
they say the purpose of public education
in the public school is uh is to teach
them what society
needs them to know as if society is kind
of like this
this monolith this organism
declaring
what kids need to know
but it's not society no it is very
specifically the government
this is why i always try you know we say
public school because everybody knows
what you mean but really we should be
using
words like government school
state-run school
the left
they're very smart about about the use
of language
they do this very effectively
the only difference is that for them
when they're
adjusting the way that they use language
they're doing it in a dishonest way
because they want to mislead you
here this is about we should be
adjusting our language um in order to to
make me the meaning more clear
in order to be more honest about what
what what uh we're referring to
which is why this is something i think
we should all do from now on just stop
saying public school stop saying it
it's that's not really what it is
public schools because it's not about
the pub the public generally speaking
doesn't run the schools
and in the schools in fact do not
reflect
what the public wants the kids to know
even if it did by the way
that wouldn't matter to me as a parent
i mean i i don't give a damn what the
public wants my kids to know or what the
public needs my kids to know
i don't care what society
even if i could know what society thinks
or wants my kids to be taught doesn't
make a difference to
me mean i'll tell society to piss off
the way that i'll tell the government
but as it stands no these are not these
are not society schools these are
government schools so let's call them
now let's just we can all pledge from
this moment forward
stop saying public school government
school state-run school that's what they
are
and so it reflects what the government
wants your kids to know
that's a really important point that we
should always emphasize
from uh this is from axios it says
donald trump is trashing ron desantis in
private as an ingrate with a dull
personality and no realistic chance of
beating him in a potential 2024 showdown
according to sources who've recently
talked to the former president about the
florida governor
um and then it uh that's pretty much all
the information the article goes on for
a while but that's pretty much
the entire report
now
of course there's always a grain of salt
when you hear
anonymous sources and everything like
that
from the corporate media
in general but especially in reference
to uh to president trump
in this case
i mean there's there's nothing about it
that raises a red flag for me that makes
me think it's not true
i'm not going to sit here and say oh
donald trump would never say that about
a potential opponent that's
but the donald trump i know would
certain never insult a potential
political opponent
um it does that doesn't surprise me i
tend to believe it
and trump has already started
a little bit gingerly by his standards
anyway he's never you know he could ever
be too
delicate when it comes to criticism but
he has started relatively delicately
diplomatically um to kind of criticize
ron desantis without without naming
names
now just a couple of days ago he was uh
doing another interview where he started
where he started criticizing republicans
who haven't publicized their vaccine
status
which is a total leftist talking point
by the way that is a leftist talking
point that you have a responsibility for
some reason to tell people what your
vaccine status is
whether you've been vaccinated or not
but we don't need to rely on anonymous
sources to tell us that trump said that
we he's on tape saying multiple times
he's been saying this
frequently in in recent weeks
and he even said
that it's cowardly it's cowardly for
republicans uh who if they don't
announce and advertise whether they've
been vaccinated or not
that would appear to me to be pretty
clearly a
thinly veiled attack on ron desantis
it's also again
off base not true and a leftist talking
point it's none of your damn business
it's nobody's business whether ron
desantis has been vaccinated
nobody nobody's business whether you've
been vaccinated whether i've been
vaccinating none of your business
you don't owe that to anybody
you don't owe your your medical records
um
so i think we're going to see this it's
going to be it's going to be more
explicit in the months ahead i mean i i
would give it like a month maybe
before donald trump is naming names and
uh coming after ron desantis coming
after him hard
cause that's how trump operates he
doesn't know how to do it any other way
and this is my fear you know that um
i mean i believe without it without a
shadow of a doubt
that ron desantis would be a much more
formidable
general election
opponent for the democrats and also a
better president
um and he's proven that with the way
that he governs
and let's start with the fact that ron
desantis did not hand his state over to
the covid cartel donald trump did that
with the country he handed the country
over to fouchy you make all excuses you
want oh you learned his lesson he's
still learning he's a 78 year old man
don't tell me we gotta elect him again
because he learned his lesson yeah you
know he tried he'll do better next time
that's not good enough
the country's at stake
all i know is that with two potential
candidates we've got one who handed his
um
his government over to the coveted
cartel and one who didn't i'm gonna take
the guy who didn't
i'm not going to take the guy who did
hoping that he doesn't do it again
so i think ronda sanchez will make a
better president and a better general
election
opponent
but i don't see him winning primaries
and one of the reasons is that donald
trump
will try to destroy this man
not just
say oh i disagree with some of his views
or i think i'd be you know i really
respect ron desantis he's a great guy
great governor everything but
but uh you know i i think i i think you
should elect me for this and that reason
now if that's the way that trump
approached it then it's not the end of
the world i mean trump wins and then we
could still have ron desantis will
survive to fight again and maybe he's
the president in 2028
but trump doesn't do that
he's going to try to rip you to shreds
and destroy you forever
which by the way is a is a nice approach
when you're going after your actual
enemies
but he does this with allies
he does this with um
people who are important to the cause
and so that's my fear
that this will happen with ron desantis
he'll just be ripped ripped apart and um
it'll be the
early extinction of his political career
at least on a national scale
all right let's play this quickly before
we get to the comments a moment of
awakening on tick tock we play a lot of
a lot of confusion a lot of delusion on
tick tock and we play that for you but
here this video went viral of somebody
just beginning to realize how screwed
they really are a red pill moment as the
kids would say let's listen
no i seriously think about this every
single day and i'm sorry if i sound
stupid
if somebody has 500
and they've already paid taxes on it and
they give it to me so now just because
it goes from them to me i also have to
pay taxes on it
even though they they just did
and then not only that but anytime i
spend one of those 500
i'm going to also pay another tax fee on
whatever item i'm buying
and then whoever i bought the item from
will have to pay taxes on the money they
just earned
from what i bought
so like if it
so every single dollar
like
if a dollar is 100 cents
hold on
just
forget it
no don't forget it you're almost there
you were almost there you're putting it
together
she was on the precipice and then she
got confused and said never mind
but i know it's scary it's scary to
think about
the fact that uh every dollar is taxed
down to about like 30 cents probably
but that's true
every dollar you make is taxed 50
different ways
everything i mean every everything you
do is every time you turn on a light
it's it's taxed
every time you drive your car it's taxed
so you buy you go to the grocery store
it's tax i mean you're taxed on the way
to the grocery store when you're when
you're using gasoline in your car your
tax everything you buy at the grocery
store is taxed
i mean just just like think about
your average day or just the process of
um
you know running errands or something
and how many times you're taxed
you get up in the morning you turn on
the lights you're taxed
you go take a shower you're running the
water you're taxed
you go eat breakfast on all the stuff
that you're taxed on and all the food is
your tax done
then you walk outside you get in your
car you're you go to the gas station tax
tax tax tax
you go to the store you're taxing all
that
you go to your job
and every dollar that you earn is taxed
in fact the government is going to take
the money is going to is going to dip
their hands into your paycheck
and take what they want
before you even see your paycheck so
they'll the government will come in and
they'll take their bit
and then they'll give you the leftovers
so you don't even get a paycheck you get
the leftovers after the government is
taken and sometimes they'll take more
than they're owed and they'll just hold
on to it with no interest and they'll
give it back to you at the end of the
year and say oh sorry we took too much
uh but no interest on that but of course
though if you owe us money
and um you don't give it to us on time
you're gonna owe interest but if we owe
you money and we don't give it to you on
time then we don't pay any interest
and most people will get their their tax
refund at the end of the year and
they'll celebrate oh free money yay i'll
go buy a tv
that's your money you ignoramus
this is not something to be happy about
that could have been you could have
invested that
even if you put it in a savings account
it's going to earn more interest than
the the you get from the government
put it under a mattress you'd be better
off
so that's right um now and then and then
you consider
that
the founding fathers
uh
you know we we don't want to go with the
with the old elementary school version
of the revolutionary war and simplify it
too much
uh there were many factors playing into
it but they were certainly we could say
at the very least uh one of the
one of the uh
leading factors was attacks on t that's
one of the things that uh
that
helped propel us
towards the revolutionary war and the
formation of this country
so our founding fathers they didn't even
want to pay a tax on tea
i mean we we pay taxes on tea these days
and like literally everything else
and uh that's that is i think that's one
of the ultimate red pills to to realize
that
you go from there well that's that's the
question
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
so we did unveil a brilliant innovative
new uh
portion of the show yesterday where we
are going to accept video comments as
well as just your standard boring
written comments you go to dailywire.com
sweet baby comments and submit your
video comments we got a couple just to
get us started and uh let's watch
hey matt so one time in college they
gave us an example of voter suppression
and it was a
news story of a
95 year old black lady in a wheelchair
who couldn't find a ride to the voting
booths and that was
apparently an example of racial
suppression
so
uh even at the time as a highly
indoctrinated liberal i was like what
so that's the only example they ever
gave me and
so there's one for you
okay there's one i mean that reminds me
of the other week when i went i wanted
to order um chinese food on ubereats but
the chinese place that i wanted order
from um
it was i was outside of the delivery
area and so and that was a case of meal
suppression i was actually i was being
starved in fact
it was a violation of the geneva
convention
it's a human rights violation
because if i cannot if i cannot
conveniently be given the food that i
want then in effect i'm being starved to
death
and that's what happens when you equate
inconvenience with a violation of rights
so you can't get a ride somewhere that's
an inconvenience no one's taking your
rights away
and and by the way
do you know whose responsibility it's
not it's not um the government's
responsibility to make sure that
everybody has a ride to the voting booth
on election day
that's not the government's
responsibility
okay you know his responsibility that is
well if a 95 year old woman i'm
certainly not going to say that it's her
responsibility to get into a car and
drive i i am fully in support of 95 year
old women not driving
but
that's your family your family should be
doing that so we have families for
it's not the government's job
and uh we got one more let's watch this
i think we should all be obliged to say
sbg for life or sweet baby gang for life
at the end of every video comment i
think if we don't we should be banned
sbg for life
i like your idea it's good to get these
ideas out um kind of brainstorming but i
i would also say
that um you know that's a good way to
end the video but you want to begin
and this is a i think a policy i'm gonna
put in place begin your video comment by
stating your pronouns uh so i made an
exception on the first day but no more
after that because you know you know me
this is a progressive show
and i need to know how to address
all the commenter commenters all right
this is from tie my shoe as we go to the
boring
written comments yuck uh says matt since
every american making minimum wage is
rich by world standards does that mean
we're all doomed from the perspective
perspective of matthew matthew 19 24
also does it reflect insanely bad on a
pastor that's wealthy even if his wealth
is only from his books
even if he's generous
yeah i think um
the fact that we're all rich by
rich by historical standards i mean most
of us are we have we have wealth beyond
the wildest imagination of
almost everyone that's lived on earth up
until now
and i think that that means that we
should certainly all be a lot more
generous than we are
because almost all of us have excess
wealth and a lot of it in fact
and i think there are many people that
would hear that and they would say well
talk about i don't have excess wealth
speak for yourself well when you
consider how much money you waste
how much money we all waste
and are able to waste
and still survive
that's that speaks to excess wealth
and um and that's
we should be generous with that a lot
more than than probably all of us are i
mean we call we could all stand to be
more generous and i think the thing that
we do
is we kind of rationalize we say well
you know i want to i want to start
giving more to charity i want to start
being more generous more charitable
there are all these causes out there
that i want to contribute to but
uh i'll start doing that when i and then
you set this kind of goal post for
yourself and say well when i get to this
point financially then i'll do that
and then you and then you you get to
that point you say oh yeah i really
don't have it in the budget so once i
get to this point
because as you're as you make more money
you end up with more expenses
and you end up developing more expensive
tastes as well you sort of expect more
luxury and comfort in your life and so
you just start you end up spending all
of that excess and not giving it away so
i would agree with you there and um as
far as pastors who are um obscenely
wealthy does it reflect poorly on them
yeah of course it does
being a pastor is not supposed to be a
um
a position that makes you rich
there's just there's
if you're looking for a
justification in the gospel for pastors
becoming rich from their preaching and
writing books also is preaching so
you're not going to find it
um
history and headlines says what should
what should be criminalized but
currently isn't
well that's that's a question i got to
start with at the beginning of the show
because i could spend the entire show on
it i mean
what should be criminalized that isn't
my list is uh
is a mile long of course leaving your
shopping cart in the parking lot
obviously chewing with your mouth open
calling a meeting when you could just
send an email or making a phone call
when you could have just sent a text
message
that should all be criminalized
small talk obviously
bumper stickers
all bumper stickers they're all annoying
and should be and should be prohibited
we don't sell bumper stickers do we in
our store
if we do then all bumper stickers except
for those should be criminalized so
that's just a very brief list david says
matt what was your reaction to elon musk
name dropping you
i have no idea what you're talking about
but
if anyone could fill in the blanks on
that i'd be interested to know
um
jonathan swank says sorry matt but my
soul is the one thing i will not sell
you well then you're not a committed
enough member of the sweet baby gang
you gotta choose your soul or the sweet
baby gang okay or you're banned
um
and uh
tip dia says matt stay-at-home moms
don't pay federal income tax so your own
wife wouldn't qualify to vote under your
proposed rules for voting shouldn't
conservatives be encouraging mothers to
stay home with their children instead of
penalizing them for it that's why i said
households
tax-paying households not individuals
you know i think you can make an
argument my my proposal all along is
let's start with the very brief 10
questions civics quiz before voting if
we could put that in place then then
i'll i'll be happy for now i mean that
would be a great improvement already
but in an ideal scenario yeah i think
you could start looking at um only tax
paying households
though some might argue that each
household only has one vote decided by
the income incomer
some might argue for that i'm not i'm
not saying i argue for it i'm saying
some do okay that's all
i'm very excited to announce the release
of the final trailer for our first
original production shut-in a seat
gripping thriller that will be available
to stream in early february the film
follows the story of a young mother who
is barricaded inside a closet by her
violent ex-husband and she as she's
trapped inside she uses nothing but her
voice to guide her children on the other
side of the walls to safety all while
the threat of her dangerous ex-looms
pretty exciting stuff uh here's the clip
[Music]
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
[Music]
well go to shut in film.com to watch the
full trailer and get ready for the
film's release on february 10th the film
is exclusive to the daily wire so if
you're planning on adding this to
your cue and want us to keep making
content to combat the over politicized
mainstream entertainment entertainment
streaming on major platforms head to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member today
well the daily wire was one of the first
in the nation to file suit against the
bite administration's tyrannical vaccine
mandates in our case made it to the
supreme court who ultimately sided with
us and blocked the mandates you can tune
in tonight to catch an all-new episode
of backstage where we discuss the
outcome of the supreme court ruling and
so much more join me ben shapiro jeremy
boring michael knowles and andrew clavin
tonight at seven o'clock p.m eastern 6
pm central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel dailywire now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
a cancellation begins with a woman in
canada who found herself stranded in the
middle of a frozen river
standing on top of her car as it sunk
into the depths below
nobody quite knows why she was driving
on the river in the first place
many jokes about female drivers might be
made here but i condemn
those crass and sexist attempts at humor
just because one woman drives on a
frozen river that doesn't mean that all
women are bad drivers every woman in the
world has earned that distinction
through her own efforts
besides we don't actually know if this
is a woman based on that picture
it's not totally clear
we could only assume she's a woman
because you know
her car's in the river in any case as a
picture taken of the scene shows the
unnamed woman as she stood on the hood
of her sinking car did have the presence
of mind to take a selfie
oops hashtag thin ice
if the photo of six marines raising the
flag on iwo jima captures and defines
the greatest generation but i think this
photo of a woman smiling for the camera
while her car sinks into the ice
captures and defines ours
if i had to explain modern western
culture to someone who to an alien who
just visited from mars and i i only had
one picture to do it it would probably
be this one
so the point is she's not anomalous her
first instinct even in a moment when her
very life is in danger was to document
the event
with her with her face front and center
so that if she manages to survive she
could at least cash in for a few dozen
likes and shares
a risk well worth taking i guess
and this is where the selfie obsession
ultimately leads
and that's why today i'm i'm cancelling
not just this woman i mean she's done a
pretty good job of canceling herself but
all selfies
in fact to paraphrase donald trump i am
calling for a moratorium on selfies
until we figure out what the hell is
going on
now it's hard for those in the younger
generations to believe but there was a
time
before selfies there was a time before
people carried cameras around in their
pockets everywhere they went
you know there was a time when like you
had cameras but you would have to
specifically bring it because you
thought you might need it
and back in those ancient times if you
had an experience
or an event occurred or you witnessed
something notable
usually your choice most of the time
was to simply experience it in the
moment to store it in your memory inside
an organ called your brain and if you
wanted someone else to know about this
event or occurrence you would be forced
to simply tell them about it using
actual words if you can believe it
and all of this changed with the advent
of the cell phone before the selfie
craze took hold there was the
documentation craze
every semi-notable and entirely
unnotable event had to be freeze framed
and shared
all of modern civilization began to
experience their lives
through these little lenses
so they could look back and remember
that time when they were only sort of
there to see it in real life
we were in this period uh the
documentation era before it had fully
transitioned to the selfie era when my
wife and i went on our honeymoon to
jamaica aboard a cruise ship and i
remember one evening on the ship leaving
jamaica standing on the deck watching
the sunset over the ocean with the
island you know in the in the distance
and i recall the breeze and the sound of
the water crashing against the hull and
the smell of the ocean and the pizza
buffet and
the sweaty ob sun lotion bodies all
around wafting through the air i
remember the cocktail in my hand and
the dread of realizing that i'd be
getting a bill for all these drinks once
we got back to miami and that all of our
wedding money would go to pay for the
drinks
it was a moment of many different layers
like all moments but i lived every layer
i lived that moment because there may
never be another like it i wanted to be
in it i wanted to be present for it but
all around us
the throngs of the other passengers all
stood watching the sunset but watching
it through their camera
hoping to get the picturesque shot of
the sun sinking below the horizon
it was a moment as big as the ocean
itself but these people all experienced
it through a two inch screen and for
what why to get a picture of a sunset
there are a million of those online
google image search ocean sunset look at
all the pictures nobody cares nobody
cares about a picture of a sunset
pictures of sunsets are a dime a dozen
worthless
actual sunsets those are priceless
but these people sacrifice the actual
sunset
in order to get a copy of a fake one and
for what i ask for likes
for the sake of making your friends
jealous well they'll be jealous for a
second but then they'll move on because
they don't care that much nobody cares
so put your camera away and be here just
be be with us now
there's only one now this is all you get
don't you people understand
i wanted to scream that but i didn't
i just ranted to my wife later and she
went to sleep thinking god help me i'm
married a crazy person which is the same
thing she's thought before going to bed
probably every night since for the past
10 years
but it's only gotten worse since then
the world i mean not my marriage
of course you know we still obsessively
document everything but our egomania
unchecked and encouraged has begun to
consume the world around us
because now we're mostly interested in
documenting ourselves our faces our
bodies us
we take a thousand pictures a day and
999 of them are of us
we experience life with our back turn to
it think about that
we turn our back to the world so we can
capture the sunset or the mountains or
the tiger at the zoo or our car sinking
into the ice
complimented by our smiling mugs
these things aren't significant enough
on their own apparently it's not enough
to simply document them no we need them
documented with ourselves at the
forefront
it's bad enough to live each moment
through a small screen it's even worse
to live it through a screen turned into
a mirror
where the event becomes mere background
for our facial expressions
so there are two categories of selfies
one is one that you take when there's
nothing special going on
you're sitting in a starbucks and
suddenly beset by the narcissistic
impulse to capture another image of
yourself
to add to a catalog that now numbers
into tens of thousands
in that case the picture is useless i
mean why do you need to capture the
moment
are you really going to go back and
reminisce about the you know the tuesday
afternoon when you drink a latte at a
starbucks in cincinnati
the other category of selfie is the one
taken when there is something special
happening some event worth noting some
site worth seeing in which case you're
ruining the picture by including your
ugly face in it
imagine the narcissism narcissism it
requires to to make a you know you're on
your torus or something and you make the
grand canyon
into the mirror backdrop for another
picture of your stupid head
many people have fallen to their deaths
at canyons cliffs volcanoes
because they were so focused on framing
themselves in a picture
they forgot about the existence of
gravity
they died to take a picture that nobody
cares to even see
this is what people need to understand
nobody cares to see your selfies
nobody you can take pictures of your
face all day long nobody cares nobody
wants to see it i know you want them to
want to
you you want everyone to care because
you're you and that's your face and the
very youness of you ought to be of great
concern to everybody in the universe but
it's not
you have people in your life who care
about you and who want to who know you
and love you and want you to be happy
and they might even be interested in the
things that happen in your life but they
especially don't care about yourself is
because they know what you look like
the rest of us are strangers and your
selfie is only another egoistic
declaration amid a torrential downpour
of them
another grinning mug shot in a
never-ending collage of pointless
self-portraits
it's meaningless to us and it's
meaningless to you
i think the world be a better place
if we all stop taking pictures of
ourselves
because then we'd be living at least if
we pulled the cameras away from our
faces
and the phones
we'd be able to find meaning in things
a meaning that extends quite a bit
beyond hey this will get a bunch of
comments on instagram
we've all had the experience of like
sitting next to a booth full of women at
a restaurant
who spend no no less than half an hour
sometimes longer taking pictures of
themselves and each other precious time
with friends wasted by a compulsive need
to get extensive footage of the
encounter
capturing memories of the time when they
spent the whole time capturing memories
it's a tragedy
it's also really annoying
and that ultimately
is why today
this woman but also all selfies
are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy
boehring our supervising producer is
mathis glover our technical director is
austin stevens production manager
pavlodowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire on today's episode the
fbi reveals new information on the
synagogue hostage situation
more fallout from novak djokovic's fight
with australia and now convicted galaine
maxwell says she'll no longer protect
the identities of her customers
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire